[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora la prima cosa da dire è che mi
sono portato la claque chiaramente e
sono qui per mi hanno detto
per farvi un dono per raccontarvi una
storia è questa storia inizia nel giorno
in cui ho contattato una delle
organizzatrici del tehrik ovvero cecilia
ero a casa e stavo guardando the peak
delle edizioni passate
incuriosito dalla singolarità degli
argomenti quando all'improvviso ha avuto
come una sorta di illuminazione un'idea
avevo un'idea così ho preso il computer
ho scritto subito una mail che ho
inviato così di getto dicendo che avevo
un'idea che sapevo sarebbe stata
perfetta per il pubblico di tette non
sono solito agisce d'impulso ma questa
volta è accaduta
non mi aspettavo la risposta di cecilia
che è arrivata in giornata e che diceva
va bene chiamami subito
beh adesso vediamo subito fantastico
quest'apertura improvvisa mi è piaciuta
adesso la chiamo e le dico la mia idea
ma quale idea così da buono psicologo di
me stesso mi sono fermato e mi sono
ascoltato
ho provato a sentire quale era l'idea
dentro di me che voleva venire fuori
qual era il contenuto che voleva
emergere da questa interazione potrei
parlare del rapporto che ho con mio
fratello ma sarebbe una cosa troppo
personale e poi lui di sicuro non
sarebbe d'accordo no potrei parlare di
cosa vuol dire crescere in un piccolo
paesino del sud che si chiama 15 di
1.500 abitanti a rovigo
potrei parlare di come si raggiunge il
successo se solo sapesse come si fa
niente
l'idea si era nascosta dentro di me si
era rifugiata da qualche parte forse
spaventata dal troppo troppa apertura
dell'organizzatrice e se volesse
fregarmi no basta basta paranoia adesso
la chiami e le dici la prima cosa che ti
viene in mente se andrà bene bene
altrimenti vuol dire che avrei fatto una
figuraccia
così prende il telefono compongo il
numero la chiamo e trento sono al
citofono posto il telefono con al
citofono e dell idea renzo e invece era
la mia compagna sa le sue le dico quello
che stavo facendo che avevo fatto questa
donazione di impulso non sapevo nemmeno
io perché è lei mi dice che la mia era
una fantastica idea che aveva avuto
un'ottima pensate che sicuramente avevo
tante cose da condividere con le persone
di interesse
io le dico che sono stato uno stupido
non avrei mai dovuto farlo avrei dovuto
pensarci prima come me è potuta venire
in mente una cosa del genere e poi
all'improvviso mi viene fuori una frase
che un bambino mi ripeteva un po di
tempo fa e che fa così non chiama con la
erre moscia
eccola è l'idea è nata a 12 anni in
realtà si chiama lucas e porta dei
lunghi capelli biondi
lucas è un bambino ma non è un bambino
come tutti gli altri oltre a essere un
bambino lucas è un poeta
lucas è un anticonformista
lucas è un rivoluzionario lucas è un
filosofo e anche un pensatore a
differenza di tutti gli altri bambini o
meglio in comune con tutti gli altri
bambini a lucas non piace andare a
scuola ma a differenza di tutti gli
altri bambini lucas non ama tanto
giocare
lucas ama più viaggiare e vedere posti
nuovi nel mondo lucas ama i grattacieli
di new york luca sala ma le cascate del
niagara lucas ama vedere città nuove che
sorgono come ad esempio e dubai
ma più di ogni altra cosa su tutte le
altre cose a luca schiacciano i
gonfiabili lucas farebbe qualsiasi cosa
pur di andare sui gonfiabili
pensate che a sette anni è scappato di
casa ed è andato sui gonfiabili nel
parco vicino casa
per fortuna che la polizia l'ha
ritrovato altrimenti probabilmente
starebbe ancora lì a saltellare e
[Musica]
lucas ama la musica classica ma non
quella che potevamo possiamo ascoltare
tutti dei buzzi non gli piace chissà
giovanni allevi non glie l'ho mai fatto
ascoltare a lui piace lo stabat mater di
pergolesi il lago dei cigni di
ciajkovskij lucas non ama vedere le cose
in disordine a casa sua
in particolare lucas non ama vedere le
fronde dei tappeti che si confondono in
una con le altre devono stare belle
allineate con affianca all'altra i guai
a chi osa toccarti a dimenticavo due
piccoli particolari
lucas ha un disturbo dello spettro
autistico e un deficit intellettivo
o meglio conosciuto come ritardo mentale
e quello che una volta chiamavamo
ritardo mentale
un'altra cosa che ha dimenticato di dire
su lucas è che quando le cose rotte a
casa sua quando le cose si rompono a
casa sua si portano giù in cantina e
così quando si è rotto lo stereo con cui
ascoltavamo la musica lucas ha voluto
portarle aggiustare lucas è davvero un
poeta e come queste tante altre che
adesso non sto qui a raccontarvi sarebbe
difficile davvero spiegarvi che cos'è un
disturbo dello spettro autistico in 11
minuti e 27 secondi in questo momento
anche perché di solito si dice su
l'autismo che ogni bambino con autismo è
diverso da un altro ma d'altronde ogni
bambino anche diverso da un altro e
quindi sarebbe una difficoltà al
quadrato quella di spiegarvi l'hotel
autismo
spero con questo talk di incuriosirvi e
spero che una volta tornati a casa
possiate dedicare cinque minuti alla
ricerca su google di che cosa l autismo
ma torniamo a noi quando ho conosciuto
lugas luca si stava malissimo
passa la giornata ea dare a calce al
muro
dare calci a letto urlava stava male e
anche noi stavamo male perché non
capivamo che cosa avesse poi complice un
intervento farmacologico e psicologico e
anche comportamentale luca lucas ha
iniziato a fare sempre meglio
sempre meglio sempre meglio i
comportamenti problema si sono sono
diminuiti e abbiamo potuto iniziare a
instaurare una relazione a conoscerci
luca sono nè di molte parole però
potevamo giocare insieme
così un giorno sono andato a casa sua
con in testa le mie belle idee su quello
che avrei fatto con lui in gergo sfitte
di gergo tecnico si chiamano programmi
programmi di apprendimento e avevo in
testa che cosa fare con lui
ma quel giorno lucas ha iniziato a
parlare come non aveva mai fatto prima
di quel momento
nelle cose
va bene
ora lasciano capire
no no no non molto vedere cosa ancora
primarie prima 210 prima street uniti
appoggiare anno prima se la cosa al
principe altra prima 8
prima c'è la donna prima in un cerchio
prima sera non aiutano di più ce l'hanno
io prima buona non certo c'è la scena
come era quasi una donna per amico era
piccola ed era felice mi manca molto a
conoscevano prima c'era il nome nonno a
comprare contrarre contare appoggerà
contro raccontare aporti è l'album che
ha non c'erano prima e ora non è felice
o triste ora ora che il nome già visto
invece quando c'era problema tra noi
c'era no no no c'è acqua c'erano prima
c'è la donna diversi marco zacchera
nonno apache dal nonno a cena dopo c'è
la mamma contrarsi pure se fosse qui
fratello cerchio ora non c'è più
no contro prima attaccante prima due
prima h prima del buio e ora prima il
cedro chieda che francesco celano
prima se ne andò così apollo e ora non
c'e
a questo punto buttato via i programmi e
ho preso un foglio di carta lo diviso a
metà e ciò scritto da una parte prima e
dall'altra dopo e da una parte ho
disegnato lucas con suo padre sua madre
e il nonno e dall'altra parte ho
disegnato lucas ma senza nonno però con
i due genitori ho pensato che se avesse
visto che non era solo probabilmente si
sarebbe sentito meno sconfortato stavamo
cercando di evitare di introdurre dei
concetti molto complessi come il
paradiso il cielo però qualcuno deve
avergli detto che il nonno si trova in
cielo così da quel giorno
lucas è diventato un appassionato di
pianeti stelle astronauti e di marte e
anche dei piccioni con cui ogni tanto
parla giocandoci proibita e qualche
volta lucas
inoltre si ferma davanti a una finestra
davanti alla finestra di casa sua e
inizia a guardare il cielo che con il
tito dipinge delle traiettorie sopra le
nuvole
chissà forse nella speranza di
rincontrare il suo nonno bella storia mi
ha detto sicilia ma ti manca l'idea
l'idea mia cara sicilia
e a tutti voi e che senza gli altri
siamo persi che se quel giorno non fosse
arrivata la mia compagna probabilmente
mi sarei perso nelle mie idee e
probabilmente non sarei qui a parlare
con voi che se lucas non avesse superato
un suo limite strutturale per potermi
parlare probabilmente se si sentirebbe
ancora molto solo
e ancora molto sconfortato che se io
quel giorno non l'avesse ascoltato
probabilmente stare ancora pensando
perché programmi di apprendimento fare
con con lucas invece di dedicare del
tempo per potere ascoltare per poter
condividere quello che lui quello che
lui aveva da dirmi
l'idea è che le migliori idee che
possiamo avere le abbiamo quando siamo
in contatto con gli altri con le persone
che amiamo e con le persone che ci amara
grazie